Guys, welcome to the call.
Welcome to the freaking live digital landlords call that we do every single week at 7 a.m.,
every day, every week of the year, unless I'm on a plane or unless I'm in the bush with
no internet, okay?
One thing that I do need to do, before I forget, hold on.
I do need to get a piece of paper because I always, when I'm doing these calls, I get
all these great ideas and then I need to write them down, like I just barely had one.
So give me just a second, I'm going to write this, it's the 26th I think, no, it's the
25th?
Dude, it was the 26th or 25th yesterday.
Um, all right, okay, guys, can you hear me?
Can somebody give me a comment and let me know if they can hear me really, really quick?
Stephanie, Richard, maybe my, dude, that's, I bet you it's my, uh, I bet you it's my stupid
Facebook.
Let's see here.
Yeah, it is, that's really crazy, I can't even see the comments as they come in.
So I'm going to have Porter read the comments because it lags.
Kevin Williams, what's up?
Kurt Dahlstrom, what's up?
Gina Benson, what's going on, Adair, um, I don't know why there's no notification that
I'm going live.
Sorry about that, Kevin Moss, I'm glad that you found me.
Maybe what we should do, Porter, if you're listening right now, tag everyone, uh, actually
let me just let Porter know really quick.
Yo.
Hey, what's up?
Can you hear me?
Yeah, I can.
What's up, dude?
How are you doing?
I'm good, man.
Hey, um, I just want to see, first of all, if they can see both of us because this has
been a really weird thing with Zoom.
Oh, great.
I want to see me.
That's a phenomenal.
Okay, bro, here's what you're going to do.
Hop off and, uh, and then I think if you get on, I should be able to just bring you on
live.
Yeah.
Hop off and just, just watch it as a guest or make a comment.
Let me see if I can bring you on that way.
Cause for some reason, something's up with my stripe or my stripe, my, uh, my zoom, by
the way, welcome Erwin McKenzie.
Yeah.
Hop off and just join as a guest, dude.
And I'll try to bring you on.
Cool.
Okay.
I'll hop off.
Cool.
My comments are finally showed up.
Erwin McKenzie.
What's going on, dude?
I think this is your first live call.
Welcome to the call.
Clellan Bradshaw.
What's up?
Uh, from Beaver, Utah.
Good to have you on, dude.
Mahmood.
What's up?
Stephanie can hear me.
Fine.
Uh, some people got the notification.
Some people didn't.
I have no idea what's going on.
Laura Shepherd morning.
All right.
We're going to try to get Porter.
Hopefully Porter can, uh, join.
Okay.
Let's see if I can get Porter to come on here.
Why doesn't it give me the option to bring Porter on?
It gives me the option to bring on other people.
Uh, that's weird Porter.
I don't know.
Just keep, keep commenting or say something because I, it says I can bring on Gina.
It says I can bring on Kevin.
You know what, Porter?
Try it.
Try to turn it on from your phone and see if that happens.
Okay.
Mahmood says I lost the fight with Raul.
That's my daughter.
She got my nose.
Yeah.
I think.
Yeah, basically.
Um, I got a little preventative, uh, dermatology done guys.
I got some spots burnt or frozen off my nose.
So I'm in just recovery phase here, but it had to happen at some point.
Um, let me see if I can just get Porter on really quick guys.
Then we'll just get going.
I got a few things I want to say.
But I don't know why you have Porter.
Try to jump on from your phone.
Try to watch from your phone and, uh, yeah, let's see.
Really need to get Porter on this thing.
Let's see.
It keeps saying Kevin Masa.
Watching.
That's good.
That is so strange.
Um, let me see if I say at Porter.
Try to watch from your phone.
Yeah, I'm not really sure what's going on with my zoom these days guys.
It's going crazy.
I'm going to have to, I'm going to have to, okay, there that is, that's going to work.
It's going to say, I think it's giving me the option.
It says I can, it says I have the little green button there, bud.
All right.
Let me see if I can pull it up from my computer.
Let Porter on and then we'll shake and bake here.
Let's see if I can find myself live.
It shows the, aha, there we go, wait, Porter, did that send you notification, bud?
I think we're good.
I think we're going to be able to do it.
Your audience is set to custom.
What is going on people?
Audience set to custom.
Why are there so many settings?
Why can't we just go live?
Ah, boy, audience.
That's crazy.
Porter, it says I'm, I'm, I'm letting you on.
Nick Ford, what's up, dude?
All right.
If I hold on to your name, dude, it's given me this option.
If anyone could tell me what to do here, it says your audience is set to custom.
So many people you select can watch this live broadcast.
That's great.
Hmm.
Okay.
One more thing.
Just give me one second, guys.
If this doesn't work, we're going to, we're going to improvise here, how to change my
audience from custom.
Just see really quick.
There's a way on the menu, top right at Facebook.
Okay.
This should be just a second here.
All right.
It says on my post, hit the buttons, oops, hit the buttons, whoops, whoops, whoops, whoops.
Tap your name, scroll down to the post, tap my name, scroll down to the post.
Oh, boy.
Okay.
I think this will work.
Let's hope.
If not, then we're just going to go anyway.
Groups, DL, and let's try this.
Select change audience.
Ah, well, no.
Well, all right, guys.
There we go.
That's great.
I'm going to put Ashley in charge of this today as the only task that she has to do.
Um, wild.
I don't know.
Okay.
Here's what we're going to do.
We're going to improvise.
Yeah, Porter.
Porter, just hop back on the link.
I'll try to do one or two things.
You might just have to talk, dude.
Let's just do this thing.
Try to jump back on that link here.
Let me send you one more link, and then we'll just get going, guys.
Apologize for that.
While Porter's jumping on, I'm actually going to do this.
Porter, I'm going to send you a link.
I'm going to share a couple of things.
Matthew McClellan, what's up?
Wouldn't Porter be a presenter?
Yeah, I don't know.
I'm going to try to send him.
That's wild.
All right.
We're going to send this one more time, but I'm going to, I got a couple of things I want
to say without Porter jumping on anyway.
Okay.
Here we go.
One more time.
All right.
While Porter's jumping on, guys, welcome to the call.
Um, again, it's Tuesday, February 25th.
It's almost two months into the year.
Six, almost a sixth of the way done with this year.
Exciting and also terrifying, right?
Uh, I, it's exciting if you're actually doing the work, if you're, if you're on track to
hit goals, if you're seeing yourself progress, it's really exciting.
And I've been on the other, last year, I'll be honest, I was on the other side of the,
uh, by the way, Porter, I'm going to let you on just a second.
Let me just finish my thought.
Yes.
Last year I was on the other side of the coin where I was like, oh my gosh, time's slipping
by and I don't know if I think I've done anything.
Right?
Um, and I've said this a few times, guys, admittedly, last year I, uh, I was in a, in
a weird mental fog, but, um, I'm, I'm ready this year.
I'm, I'm here.
I'm ready.
I'm pumped.
Um, one thing that I draw, I want to just remind you guys of, I put this in the, uh,
the group.
I made a post about this.
If you guys have not already, I have a, uh, PDF that I share with you guys with a book
called The Slide Edge.
Go and start reading that book for just read 10 pages a day.
Do it on your phone.
That's probably the equivalent of like four or five pages on a regular book.
Just go read 10 pages of this book every single day and start to make tiny implementations
of what this book is teaching you guys.
And it's going to freaking change your business.
Okay.
Um, I don't, I don't have a kickback from this book.
That link is a free PDF.
This isn't some kind of weird affiliate thing.
It is literally just completely given me so much momentum.
Go check this book out.
I've made Porter.
Watch this or start reading this as well.
If you guys didn't see my post, go and search my name.
Type in Nick Wood, go and look for the post where I gave a, uh, this book, The Slide Edge
by Jeff Olson.
Guys, go start reading 10 pages of that.
Of course you don't have to.
It's your business.
It's your life, but it's, it's been one of the best things I've done.
I started it almost exactly a month ago and everything is completely changed in, in the
better.
And I sincerely mean that.
It sounds a little bit like a cheesier over the top, but I'm dead serious.
It's been amazing.
Okay.
Um, another thing that I was going to just say really, really quick, and this is before
Porter hops on, um, Richard says, can you send that link again?
I'm not really sure what link you're talking about.
My friend, uh, I sent the link to Porter, but he's, he's in the waiting room.
So I'm gonna let him on.
I don't know which link you're talking about, sir.
Um, you know what I was thinking about yesterday?
I was sitting on the treadmill and I have a couple of buddies that I know personally
that are in this group.
Okay.
And, uh, you actually, anyone that knows me is going to think I'm talking about them,
but there's some, there was two specific, there was actually one specific person I had
in mind.
Um, and I was sitting there thinking in my head, like I was about to text them last night
and, and say, cause I went to the gym a little bit late.
I was about to say, uh, where are you at?
Why are, why have I not seen you get a deal recently?
Why are you not, um, posting that you got to win?
You know, and I, that's how my thoughts started.
And then I just started thinking about like Porter, who I'm about to bring on, who's,
uh, at 10,700, he actually went up a hundred dollars after replacing these clients.
And I wanted to just, then I started to just get pissed off.
And I was thinking, like, guys, if you're watching this stream right now and you, like,
you're not annoyed that me and Porter are making the kind of money that we're making
from renting simple websites.
Like you don't know, like the, the, the, the basicness of our personalities, of our education
level, it should, it should piss you off.
Okay.
We are not by any means, oh, it's, you know, like we have, we have no tech experience.
We've never done websites.
We didn't grow up doing that.
We grew up literally working on the farm and, and not everyone, I know some of you guys
are beating Porter, but he's beating a lot of you guys.
Like he's kicking your butt.
He is at 10,700.
He replaced two of his clients on Saturday.
He's got another deal in the works this week.
And some of you guys are, I see you every week on the stream and you're still not getting
a deal.
Like, what are you doing?
What are you?
Are you like, are you going to ever get a deal?
Are you ever going to get the next deal?
Are you ever going to, or is it just going to be a constant blame everybody else and
the time that you don't have and the weather and the fact that you got so much going on?
It's like, so does he dude.
He's Porter's got a kid.
Porter's got a full-time thing with my dad.
Like he does every reason to make excuses.
Right.
Why don't you guys, why, why some of you guys I see in here, why didn't you get a deal
this week?
Why haven't you gotten a deal yet?
Why haven't you gotten a deal in the last month?
What are you guys doing?
Like you're getting beat by Porter.
You like, what are you doing?
Porter's kicking your butt.
Have a little bit of pride.
Get pissed off.
Doesn't mean you have to hate on Porter or wish bad on Porter.
But guys, I remember when I was just starting, I would see people posting in the group that
were making money.
And to be honest, I think they were lying because now looking back on it, those people
are, I see sometimes their Facebook friends and stuff.
I'm like, dude, they were never making any money, but that's another story.
And I would see these posts and I would just piss me off.
I'm like, and I wasn't like, oh, they took money out of my pocket.
It was like, Nick, pull your freaking head out, dude.
These guys, I'm looking at them.
I'm seeing the post, whether it was real or not.
I'm going to their profile.
I'm like, dude, this guy, I'm better than this guy.
And I don't mean that in like a arrogant way, but like, dude, I know that if this guy can
get a deal, if this guy's at $10,000 a month, this guy's at $20,000 a month, what are you
doing?
Like, what are they doing that you're not doing?
Come on.
Have a little bit of pride, guys.
I want you guys to get excited.
I want you guys to get on these calls.
I want you guys to have good energy.
But like, when is enough enough?
When is it like, dude, this is too much.
I've got to get a freaking deal, right?
Like, when are you going to draw a line in the sand and say, look, I paid to be in this
program.
I'm here.
I'm getting on the lives.
I've gone through the training.
I've chosen this as the business model.
It's time to get a deal, guys.
You might have to get scrappy.
You might have to call every single person in your phone and tell them that you do lead
generation and tell them that you can get them more leads to get your first deal.
And you might have to follow up with that with that same list.
I think Hermosy talks about this in $100 million leads.
You might have to reach out to every single person and follow up with them every single
day for the next month.
But if you took every contact, you know, that owns a business and you followed up with them
every day for a month, you cannot tell me you couldn't squeeze a deal out of that.
You could not.
You cannot tell me you can't get a $300, $500, $750, $1,000 a month deal by just squeezing
your contacts.
You cannot tell me that.
Okay, guys, me and Francesca are getting scrappy.
We're doing stuff.
We're posting.
You guys saw my post yesterday.
We're posting in yard sale groups.
We're posting here.
She's going to the Chamber of Commerce looking at this, shaking hands, kissing babies, going
around town.
We're doing all kinds of stuff, testing all kinds of stuff.
If you've been in this program for more than two months and you do not have a deal, that's
on you.
Okay, because even if you don't want to run ads, even if you don't have money to run ads,
whatever it is, you should have a deal.
That's just fact.
You have enough contacts.
You've been alive 18 plus years.
You've got enough contacts.
Even if you're 18, you don't have a bunch of big guys or big women that are your friends.
Your parents and their friends have big people.
Guys, take a little bit of pride.
Get a little bit pissed off that Porter's kicking your butt.
He's at $10,700 a month with a full-time job, with a baby, married, has every excuse not
to be making money, and he's running circles around some of you guys.
We've all got stuff going on.
When I started, I had a full-time thing doing door-to-door sales.
I had a kid, one on the way.
I had a team to manage.
I had church responsibilities, all that stuff.
Guys, I went to the gym every day, and I got deals.
What are you guys doing?
When are you going to have a freaking little bit of pride?
Let's draw a line in the sand, and let's go.
That's all I got.
Okay, let's get Porter on here.
You're not even going to be able to see him, but who cares, because some of you guys...
Porter, can you hear me?
Porter.
Hey, what's going on?
Hey, I'm just going to pin you, because apparently this is the dumbest thing ever.
I don't know.
I'm going to make you the co-host.
We're going to start with that.
Then I'm going to pin you, and then we're going to just go.
Guys, you're not going to be able to see Porter.
Sorry about that.
We're just going to roll.
Listen to his voice.
My Facebook also is lagging.
Facebook has some of the crappiest tools on the internet.
They don't want to work with anyone.
They're like Apple, but at least Apple has good products.
If Facebook wasn't so convenient, I'd get off of Facebook in five seconds.
Screw you, Mark.
All right.
I'm just annoyed right now.
By the way, slide edge.
Sorry.
That's what Richard was talking about.
Thank you, Nick.
He was talking about...
Can you share the link?
There's the slide edge.
You guys can't see Porter.
We're just going to go.
Porter, I'm going to give a little bit of a backdrop.
Porter, he was at $10,600 about a week ago.
He had a client that wasn't paying.
It was one of those deals where they're missing a payment and all this different stuff.
By the way, guys, if you do have clients like this, don't just accept it.
Don't just let them walk all over you.
Realize that you're the one that holds the keys, the leverage.
Anyway, he had this client that wasn't paying, and he knew he had to replace this client.
It's a scary thing.
No one wants to replace a client.
Sometimes we're sitting there going, man, I'll keep dealing with it.
No.
Then he had another one that I think that's another one canceled, right?
He replaced two on Saturday.
Porter, let's share your story.
Let's talk about...
Just share the story of how you lost the clients.
Then we'll go to Saturday.
Guys, I know you're not going to be able to see Porter.
I will get that fixed.
That's the first thing that Ashley's going to do when she wakes up.
If she's not awake already, zoom.
That's crazy.
I apologize, but we're just going to go with this because we want to get the information.
You're going to see me.
You're going to listen to Porter.
Porter, tell the story about how you lost the clients, dude.
Yeah.
The first one, it was actually my first ever client that I landed three years ago, or two
and a half years ago.
Yeah, old nester, dude.
Anyways, it was in Concrete, and he was behind three payments.
He always gave the mentality of...
He always paid.
I always knew he was going to pay.
He was never on time.
It was always two or three weeks past.
I was like, bro, this is so annoying.
I felt like he was almost like that weak link in my business.
I was like, dude, how am I supposed to do this if I had five or six of these same guys?
I was like, I just got to cut the fat.
As hard as it was because I was at 10,000, and I was like, dude, I don't want to drop below.
I was like, he's not paying me anyways.
I'm like, what am I doing?
I'm just sitting here.
That guy basically told him, hey, I got to go look for somebody else.
Sorry.
The next guy, I literally sent him over a lead, and then he called me or texted me.
He's like, hey, when's our four-month contract up?
I was like, oh, it's up.
We need to renew it anyways.
He wasn't closing as many jobs anyway.
He was one of those business owners where he was satisfied to get the jobs.
He was quoting them high because he was busy.
His excuse was, dude, I'm so booked out that I literally can't even take on any more jobs.
I'm basically pointless.
I'm like, well, that's a good thing.
That's what you want.
Anyways, the whole thing, I didn't even try.
Most of the time, I try to make something work.
I try to sell through a client and try to say, hey, let's try this.
This might really help you if they're not selling type deal.
This one, I was like, you can't really argue with that.
I don't know what to say.
That was Saturday of last week.
Both those happened.
Two in one day, I was like, are you crapping me?
It just takes the breath out of you when you lose two clients like that.
That's how I lost them.
Okay.
Porter went from $10,600 per month down to what?
What did that drop you to?
Well, one was $1,200.
The other one was $1,600.
That puts you at $9,400.
You were at $8,800.
Yep.
Porter went from $10,600 to $8,800 overnight.
What a way to start a Saturday.
Love that for you, bro.
What a great Saturday.
I had no idea this was going on, by the way.
Guys, first thing I want to say.
First of all, if you don't have clients, get some clients, dude.
Come on.
Let's have some pride.
Do something.
Guys, the other day I got some stuff in the mail.
You know those value packs?
It's called ValPak.
Have you guys seen those?
I got that the other day.
I saw the mail.
I had an IRS bill.
I had my insurance bill, all those bills.
Then I saw this.
I opened it up.
Dude, I went through it.
Every single one of the little coupons that was a business, that was a home service business,
I put it on the side.
Had a big old stack of them, and I think my kid threw it away.
I think Riggs threw it away.
I put it on top of the stair rail to go up to the office, and I can't find it.
But that's a great way.
Guys, they're paying for freaking leads.
They're paying money to try and get leads.
That's what they're looking for.
Those are great, warm leads.
Anyway, I'm just still on my soapbox about the fact that if you don't have a deal, then
shame on you.
If it's been two months you don't have a deal, shame on you.
Porter, if you didn't know how to do this process, you didn't know how to run ads,
don't you think if you took a list of all the people you know that do concrete, all
the people you know that do fencing, all the people you know that do tree service, that
if you called them and text them and did something every day in 30 days, you couldn't get a
deal?
Oh, for sure.
Through your contact list, I guarantee you get a deal.
Dude, go through your Facebook friends.
Every person that has a company, write it down.
Go buy Hermosy's book.
He talks about it.
He's like, you just reach out to him.
Here's what you say.
And guys, it's literally that's how simple it is.
If it's been 60 days you don't have a deal, shame on you.
Have some pride in yourself.
It's enough is enough.
Guys, we're two months into the year.
Now I'm down just getting annoyed that it's on you.
Borders using the same training that you guys are using to get deals, to replace deals.
So is everybody else out there.
Francesca, who doesn't even speak English as her first language.
Guys, she came to the US as a 16 year old kid that didn't speak English.
She's landing deals.
Not with my help, not using me.
You guys need to land deals.
Have some pride.
It's enough.
It's done.
Okay.
So first thing, guys, once you do get deals, just know that you're going to lose a client.
I don't care how good it is.
I don't care how many good leads you send.
I don't care how many, you know, whatever.
How many reports you send.
How many times you send them a card in the mail.
You're going to lose clients.
That's just the fact of the matter.
Why?
Because guys, sometimes these clients, they don't know how to close.
And that's not always the case, but that you lose them.
Sometimes it's your fault.
But sometimes, guys, they just suck at closing.
They should never be in business in the first place.
They should be working for somebody else.
But you know what?
They chose to be in business and you're going to lose clients.
So just accept the fact that you are going to lose clients.
That's just it.
Okay.
So Porter, when that happened, what was your first reaction?
Because I've done this before and I've lost clients and it's made me sick.
But I'll tell you, it's a lot worse when you're doing SEO.
But go ahead.
What was your first reaction?
What was your thoughts?
What was your feelings?
Well, the first reaction, I was kind of like, I was pissed off, first of all,
because I was like, this has happened to me before.
And I'm like, I'm providing the leads.
And you kind of just want to just say, I'm just going to take the day off.
I'm just going to lay in bed.
I'm just going to just chill.
I'll start hitting it Monday.
But I actually started hooking my clients Saturday.
I immediately got on the phone and I started calling business owners because
the last time that this happened to me, I remember it took the air out of me.
I almost stayed at two or three deals for a couple months because I literally
was being such a pansy about just getting back on the phone.
I was taking it so personal that these business owners dropped me.
And this time I just had a better mindset.
I was like, dude, I'm not letting this affect me.
Like 10K is where I'm staying.
I'm not dropping below that.
So it was just like the standard of like, I got to stay above this.
Like this, you know, you hit something, you're just like, dude, I'm doing this.
And it's crazy what you can do when you have like the willpower or just like
the, I don't know, the urgency.
I don't know if that's like a better word, survival.
In that book, it talks about being like survival.
And you're like, when you need to like do something, you will do it.
And that's kind of where I was at.
I was like, dude, I got to, I got to get some deals.
Yeah, guys, it's just about standards, right?
So this is a really simple analogy that I've heard.
You've probably heard a million times.
I'm not trying to pretend it's my own.
It's not original.
It's like we have this financial thermostat, right?
And how a thermostat works is how the analogy goes is when you have a thermostat
set at 70, if it gets to 68, the heat kicks on, right?
You go back to 70.
If it gets to 72, the cool, the AC kicks on to go back to 70.
We have this thermostat of what we think we're worth.
And as soon as we go below it, we're going to do everything we can to get to it.
It's crazy.
Like we start scrapping our way and we start going into like, I can't breathe mode.
We start going into like, this is the only thing that matters.
Nothing else is important.
I got to get back to the certain baseline and you'll do everything.
You'll get scrappy, creative, everything.
And the reverse is true, too.
You think you're worth 10K a month and you make 15K one month and all of a sudden you
start self-sabotaging.
You start taking the day off.
You start doing all this stuff.
So the key is like, how do you get your standard hire?
Some of you guys, and I'm not trying to be rude here, but clearly some of you guys have
a standard of making no money, right?
Like in this business, your standard is zero because you're not urgent.
You're not doing whatever it takes to get a deal.
You're content sitting there watching the training for the third time in a row and
tweedling around with your website when you need to just pick up the phone and call
somebody or walk into a business or go on Facebook or call your uncle or whatever.
But get a deal.
Make something happen, right?
So it's a good point.
Once you get to a certain point, guys, and I feel like when you get to these really good,
even numbers, like you get to the 10K and you kind of have this identity.
And it's really good, too, because everyone wants Porter hit 10K.
We're like, hey, Porter's at 10K.
Last thing he wants to do is drop below 10K.
He's now a 10K person, right?
When I made seven figures in 2020, it was the weirdest thing in my mind.
I was like, oh, I can't go.
I can never make less than a million dollars, right?
I can never make less than a million dollars no matter what happens.
And guys, even like, for example, last year, it was a weird year.
A lot of personal stuff took my eye off the ball in some ways.
Maybe you guys saw it.
Maybe you didn't.
But I did.
Even then, I still made far above a million dollars, like well above a million dollars,
because even with all the distraction, even with all the personal stuff, I knew, hey,
I don't make less than a million dollars.
And so this year, I sat down and I was like, it's time for me to change that standard.
Like, a million is no longer even close to acceptable.
And the same way that I'm telling you guys you should get annoyed that Porter's at $10,600,
$10,700, is I'm looking at people around me that I know that are making a million dollars a month
in one of their businesses.
And I'm like, dude, there's nothing different between that guy and me.
Why are they beating me?
What am I doing?
Why am I still content at making a couple million bucks when I should be making five figures?
I should be at $10 million a month.
I made my first million five years ago, four years ago.
You know, I should be at 10.
I should be at 10 plus, period.
What am I doing?
What are you doing, Nick?
Big wake up call.
Roll my goals down.
And this year, everything's changing.
Changing my standard.
Getting around different people.
So Porter, how did you how do you think people can change their standard of what they think they're worth?
And I don't want to get too much into like this mindset stuff because I want to keep this on tactical stuff.
But also, how does somebody that's never gotten a deal or that's barely making two, three thousand, four thousand bucks,
barely paying the bills at their regular job, how do they get the mindset of like, hey, I have to I have to make a certain amount?
Like, how do you create that?
How did you get to that point?
It definitely took a little bit of time.
I wish I would have gotten there faster because now that you've gotten there, you look back and you're like, if I would have just changed a few of these things,
I think the number one thing is I just think I was so analysis paralysis or I was too afraid to like make a jump in like spending money or doing certain things.
Like it's like you kind of just dabble, you know, for a while you're just dabbling.
You're like, I'm going to run a website, I'm going to run an ad.
And then you're like, I'm going to call a business owner.
I'm also going to call like five of them.
If one of them pick up, I'll do it.
But then it becomes like it's like, no, I'm going to do this until I get it.
I'm going to get someone on the hook.
And then it's like, no, I'm going to run this ad until I get leads.
Like, there's no reason I shouldn't because I've seen it work.
And it's like there's too many people in the group.
The thing that changed it for me was, again, seeing people in the group get deals that I knew that I thought I was better than them in a humble way.
But like I thought I could do better than them.
And so I think seeing other people get deals, I knew the process worked, but I knew it was my insecurities and my personal feelings of like what I thought I was capable of.
That was the biggest thing holding me back.
So I think I honestly for me to get to that point, I think I had to fake it until like I literally had to say, hey, I think I'm worth this, even though I necessarily don't feel like I am, but I'm going to be this.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
Like, that's kind of what you have to do until you feel that way.
Yeah, I agree.
And another thing, guys, another thing that will really help you is getting around people that are making a lot more money than you.
And I'm not saying that that should be the only thing that you look for in friends, right?
Because if they're just crappy human beings, that may not be worth it.
But we are talking about money in this group.
This group is not necessarily a group we're talking about, you know, whatever.
We're talking about money.
So in that regard, guys, one of the easiest ways to really get your standards changed or really to shake up your to really mind after yourself is start getting around people that are making way more money than you.
Right.
Because all of a sudden you start to see the way that they live their lives.
You start to see the way that they don't even think about the decisions they make aren't based on price.
They're based on convenience and time and, you know, things like that.
Like, I remember when I started hanging out with one of my only friends, I don't have a lot of friends that I really hang out with one of my only friends.
And I started to make I was starting to make a little bit of money.
I think this is around I actually became friends with them before I made my first seven figures.
But I remember that the first time I made some decent money, he's we went to Mexico and I'm like, so where are we going to stay?
And he just sent me the link.
He's like, I booked here and I pulled it up and it was like, you know, five hundred six hundred bucks a night, not all inclusive.
This is just for the room.
And I was like, you know, obviously, it can't be I got to just I can't say, oh, let's go somewhere cheaper.
I'm like, all right.
So, you know, I went there for like a five, six days.
It was like two, three, twenty five hundred three thousand dollars.
And I was like, dude, if I want to continue to be this guy's friend where I get invited to go to do stuff.
I mean, the guy's talking about like, hey, I don't let's just let's just split a private plane to go down there so we can just go straight out of, you know, St.
George Airport.
He started to make these kind of comments.
I got me like, OK, I got it.
I got to pull my head out.
What am I doing?
I'm sitting over here thinking I'm hot crap making, you know, a hundred grand a month.
This dude's making a million dollars a month.
Like, I got to step this thing up.
So, guys, you start getting around people that are making a lot more than you.
I guess I should say this, they have higher standards than you and you are naturally going to have higher standards.
Porter, how do you do that?
Because Porter lives in a town.
And by the way, there's some people in this in that town that are in this group.
And guys, welcome.
I know there's a couple of you guys that joined recently.
Dakota.
I don't know if you're on here, Dakota, but if you are, welcome, dude.
He's in a town where there's some people that are doing some things.
But a lot of the people, I would say the average income in that town, it's got to be like four grand.
Right.
Maybe monthly.
Maybe maybe four to six grand.
And people are really content with that, which in some ways I actually really respect because it's like, yeah, money doesn't make you happy.
I get that.
But it's also it's tough when you're around that type of people all the time that like you're the big frickin dog, man.
You're you're making 10 grand, dude.
You know, your your donation at church is fat, dude.
And it's like, no, you're tricking little small chimp.
You're like, you're just a little fish.
Right.
And I'm the same way compared to a lot of people, too.
How do you do that?
How do you how do you have the high standard of, you know, hey, by the way, Porter, 10 grand, you're still making baby money, bro.
Let's go.
I know.
You are, dude.
Come on.
I mean, let's see.
Twenty.
What are you?
Twenty five.
Yeah, it is unacceptable.
Twenty five, twelve.
So you're like you're ripping like 120 a year.
I mean, dude, at twenty five, I'd be like two hundred and ten.
Just no.
I mean, throw your face a little bit, a little bit, a little salt in the wound.
You got it.
You get you're not.
You got to pick this up, dude.
Twenty K.
Then we can start, you know, flexing a tiny bit.
But how do you do it, bro?
Because I know that what it's like, like and that's one of the reasons I like to be around people that are successful.
That's one of the reasons I like to be in Dubai.
I look around. I'm like, dude, every other person's got a frickin Lambo.
I don't know if it's drug money, but nonetheless, they got cash.
Dinner, seven hundred and fifty dollars for two people.
That's you got to have cash.
What what do you do when you live around people that are at a lower standard to raise the standard?
I think I try to do that that same mindset, but it's got to be online.
It's got to be within the group.
It's got to be like I'm rubbing shoulders with with obviously you.
I talked to Jeff like you talked to Francesca like you just talked to people that you know are making money or landing deals constantly.
Like Mahmood making good money.
And it just kind of just makes you wait.
Sixty five K a month. He doesn't talk that he doesn't.
Yeah, as much as that sixty five K a month.
He's a sleeper. Keep going.
Yeah. But like that, it's just like, dude, these guys are making a lot of money.
So it's like I have to like be around those people in the group.
So like, yeah, if you can't be there physically, try to be there, you know, socially on their rub shoulders with them.
Comment like I for the longest time, I hated posting because I just didn't want you.
You don't know. You don't want people to know you.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, especially I'm your brother, too.
So I'm like kind of like hiding back and whatever.
And then I'm like, you know, then you kind of change.
You're like, what's so bad about people knowing your business in a way?
You know what I'm saying?
You kind of switch the mindset.
And so I think as soon as I started doing that, I kind of just was like it was like this eye opening thing.
It's crazy when you really start to think that you're you're actually this like right now.
But you're a big fish in a small pond, but but you're really a small fish and, you know, a massive pond, right?
That's kind of what you need to be.
So I just try to do it online and the Facebook group post be around people that can motivate you.
Yeah, guys, that's one of the reasons that you you maybe you didn't even join for this reason.
But this is one of the best things about this community is think about where we all came from.
We all have our lives. We're all in our situations.
We're all surrounded by people that are living average lives.
Maybe we were in the free Facebook group.
Maybe you came from the school community, you know, whatever.
And we basically sucked all the people out of there that are ready to do this for real.
Right. And so we filtered everyone out.
And these are the people in this group that are here to do this for real.
And you are surrounded by all the winners.
Right. Ma Moon's making sixty five thousand dollars a month.
Mike V's making forty thousand dollars a month.
These are U.S. numbers, by the way.
I'm not going to say this guy's name, because I don't know if he wants me to.
But there's a guy that just joined. This is not Ryan Dalton.
He makes one hundred and twenty thousand dollars per month.
He's not talking much, but he's in the group. He just joined.
We got Ryan Dalton six hundred thousand dollars a month.
Jeff, I don't know what Jeff's at. Twenty thousand plus.
Levi's at fifteen thousand plus. Jason's at fourteen something.
Stephanie's at, by the way, shout out to Stephanie, twelve thousand nine hundred.
There's Juan Finesse's at forty thousand plus.
Russ Ether's at forty thousand plus.
Guys, you are surrounded by people that are making some freaking cheddar in this group.
So go and be of value to these people.
Do not message them and say, hey, can I jump on the phone with you?
Because I'm going to not let them. OK, they're not going to.
But like, add some value.
If you see one of them post and you have an answer or you find something valuable, share it with them.
Go and make yourself known. You don't have to be super loud.
But like Porter's been doing a really good job.
He's been sharing his wins, sharing where he's at, sharing his losses. Right.
And then people can say they know who he is.
And that's not a bad thing, because now Porter's like, I'm the 10K guy.
Well, if you're at eight today, we'd just be freaking roasting you, dude.
You can't go below ten. Right. You can't go below.
Guys, go read freaking Porter. Tell these guys about slight edge.
I had Porter start the slight edge. Give it give it a review.
What are you on page like 80?
Yeah, I'm on page like 80. But it's it's totally like when you first like the first.
It's one of those books that it's not you don't have to wait a few chapters to get into it.
It's like it like hits hard and like the first couple of pages.
Like it's insane. Right. Yeah.
It is so cool. But it just makes you like this.
It's all your mindset. And it's like you already know what to freaking do, guys.
It's just us. Yeah. You just got it. It's all these little things.
Guys, if you want to skip to a chapter talking about this, this specific topic of, you know,
learning a specific skill, Chapter 13 talks about mentors.
And that's anyway, just as a quick note.
And I know that because I've been recommending this book to a lot of people recommending certain chapters,
screenshotting pieces.
This is just a very simple book about a simple strategy that if you'll just do these things,
guys, everything's going to change for you.
Like just simple stuff. Reading 10 pages a day.
Just all like just these little tiny things. Right.
If depending on what your goals are.
For me, it's like I need to make a post every single day on certain social media channels.
I need to do.
I mean, obviously the gym to me.
That's just the standard at this point.
I need to make a certain amount of money.
But in order to make that certain amount of money, I have to do these little tiny things.
So guys, go freaking just just 10 pages on your phone every day.
What does it take you 10 minutes?
Oh, not even that.
You know, sometimes like yesterday I was eating Chipotle after the gym, which that's it.
That was a decision, right?
Like, hey, I'm going to eat this 600, 700 calorie bowl instead of going and smashing Buffalo Wild Wings and waking up groggy.
You know what I mean? Like those little tiny things.
Drinking water. I stopped drinking soda.
I stopped drinking energy drinks.
Right. These are little tiny things.
I started focusing on my sleep.
Shout out to the whoop and Christiano Ronaldo.
Your boys get that dialed in sleep.
These are all little things that are contributing.
Anyway, guys, so we're going to get back into the tactical.
So I just wanted to go on a little soapbox on that, but go check out that book.
So guys, to raise that mindset, get around people to raise the standard, get around people that are making a lot more money than you.
And this group is a perfect way to do it.
You can do it by getting on these calls and listening to the mindset, listening to the like, you know, people that have, you know, options, people that have freedom.
You get around that. It gets infectious.
They have the ability to go and do stuff that you can't.
And it's exciting and it should piss you off a little bit.
So, okay, Porter, let's talk about what you did.
So as soon as you got the news that you're losing the deals, you decided.
So you actually got the news on Saturday morning that you lost the deals.
Or does it Friday?
No, it was Saturday morning, dude.
It was the chitiest Saturday, dude.
My heart hurt. It was like my dog died or something, dude.
It's so sad, dude.
And it's worse when you have kids because you're like your kids.
You're like, dude, that just took some opportunity out of my.
We could have taken a little forward to Disney.
You know, dude, I felt so bad a little bit.
Okay.
So so you got the news on both or you the one you kind of knew was coming, but the one you hit hit you on Saturday, right?
Yeah. So it was like one.
I was like, okay, I could drop below a little bit.
Right. And then.
And so I had so I had one deal that was going to be a new deal.
So I was working on him. I had a business owner hooked.
Then I decided to just cut the cut the fat with the other guy.
And then, bam, Saturday morning, three business owners that I was like, she is broke.
Okay. So so this is an important thing, guys.
Well, soon as Porter lost the deal, he got right on it.
He got pissed off instead of being like, oh, what was me?
Oh, my. I'm a victim. Oh, oh, of course.
The Porter, you know, guys, everyone's lost deals, dude.
I lost a four thousand dollar deal at SeaWorld.
And I was making eight grand a month.
Like, dude, that's that's when you go.
That's when you're like, yeah, I don't know about that churro.
You can't tell that you can't tell wifey.
You can't tell the kids they can't have the churro.
But you're like, how am I going to pay for that?
Pay for the churro.
The churro is like eight bucks, dude, pretty pricey.
We're going back for round two.
You know what I'm saying?
It goes a long way when you just lost a four thousand dollar client.
Been there, bro.
First and foremost, guys, you this is why you build assets.
This is why you don't do you don't trade time for dollars.
You build assets because now Porter's like, OK, screw you, Bob.
Screw you. What's his name?
Nestor, dude. Yeah.
Screw you, Nestor. I feel like I had.
I feel like I worked with a guy named Nestor.
I think it was probably my old client.
Screw you, Nestor. I'm going to go to somebody else.
He just jumped on it. He used the pit.
He was pissed off and he used it to go get a client.
What did you do? Did you even have any leads to send?
Did you like did you just start rip?
Like did you have your old list or what was the first thing you did?
You go lock yourself in your office. You go on a drive.
How did you make the calls?
So, yeah, dude, I do.
So, dude, I could just rip calls in the truck, dude.
So I just get in the V10, the gas log, dude, and I start trailing the farm roads, dude.
And then I was taking these leads because this guy wasn't calling these leads because he was so booked out.
So that was the one guy.
So I was literally calling leads back like weeks and weeks.
And some of these were like, yeah, I'd love a quote.
So I sent over like two one day and then like I waited a little bit, sent another two.
So it was fast. That one was to cake.
And the other one, this one was a little bit slower.
This one was Nestor, the one I got.
So I called some of his leads that he had already quoted.
And I was like, hey, like I work with a couple of different contractors, whatever, me and this other guy working together.
But I could also send you another guy like I don't want to step on anyone's toes.
But like I could give you another option. And they're like, yeah, send them over.
So I sent them over the same lead and I let the business owner know because I didn't want him thinking I was giving this to two different guys.
But I was like, you know, I was working with this other guy, whatever. He didn't have a problem with it.
So anyways, that's what I was doing. But yeah, I was I just went in my truck, dude.
I just was like, I got to go take a little breather. And I just and I had a list already.
So I knew that like I had it already prepared because I think I hooked one of the guys like that first client I had.
It was the first call I did. So I had this whole list ready.
So I just went and started making calls right after.
Dude, one one little hack, guys, is I agree.
I definitely recommend you do your closing calls from your Zoom.
But for some reason, getting in your car and driving around and doing calls, I think it's because you're not this is not safe.
I'm not saying this is the top safety protocol here, but use your Bluetooth, whatever I get in the freaking Tesla, dude, just I recline that seat like I'm basically about to take a nap.
And, dude, I got the thing on on the Bluetooth.
And, dude, for some reason, being distracted and looking at the way I'm driving, I'm so much more calm like I'm not.
Don't get me wrong. I'm still sweating.
I'm still freaking pouring sweat down my back and my face when I'm calling, even doing it this long.
Sometimes for some of you guys that are terrified, jump in your car, go on a drive and just take your list with you and call them while you're driving.
Call them while you're walking.
Try to distract yourself a little bit like that and it will help you a lot.
Sometimes I get it when you're sitting at your desk.
It's really nervous. You're sitting there taking your feet and you're like, I don't know.
But if you're moving and doing something, it seems to help.
So Porter, thank goodness he followed the process, right?
He had the list already built.
He knew who we wanted to contact.
One thing that I like that you did, he went and called some of the old leads that he that the guy never quoted or the guy never closed.
Whatever the guy's not paying him this this guy Nestor.
So it's like he's not obligated to do anything.
He went and called him and he hustled.
He didn't say, well, I'm going to wait for some more leads to come in.
He just went and called him.
So how do you what's the pitch like to a business owner?
You have somebody you know they're going to cancel.
You can just see it.
You can smell it, right?
They missed a few payments.
They're a little unhappy.
You've got a Zoom scheduled next Thursday.
They want to review things.
You have a good feeling.
You kind of know they're going to cancel at some point.
How what do you say to the new when you're calling the new list?
What do you say to the business owner that's different than when you don't have a business owner?
I guess the only I guess I ask him different questions.
I think it's like, OK, that business owner that I just lost, what is one quality that that they have that I didn't know they had?
You know, when I started working with them, so I think I started I asked a little bit better questions.
Like maybe it's like, hey, like I really started to focus on like, hey, how much you make and how long you've been a business.
Like, I think that was his problem was he just wasn't making a lot of money.
Like he wasn't he didn't have any source of lead flow.
It was just me, which, yeah, you're fine with just doing this.
But like most other guys have their own brand or mouth, all these different things.
And so like one of the guys I quoted, dude, this is hilarious.
I got on the phone with him and he I was like, hey, how much are you making like per month?
And he's like, two. And I was like, like, two hundred thousand.
He's like, no, two million. And then I was like, OK.
And then he's like, hold on, give me one sec. And he walks out of his house and he's like, sorry, you mean my wife for going through divorce.
I don't want her to see the numbers. I don't want to hear that.
Somebody you're working with. Yeah, this is one of my clients, dude.
He was hilarious. So dogs make it two mil.
And you thought he was making way less. Yeah.
And so I literally I was like, because you just don't know, like you talked to him on the phone.
You're like, this guy is probably making a couple hundred thousand a year.
Right. And this guy takes me outside.
He's flexing all he's got, like, three fifties, like trailers, like everything.
And so in my mind, I was like, dude, I think I'd get a little bit more.
But I was like, I'm not going to be greedy. Like, this is what it's going to be worth.
Right. And so I quoted him like fifteen hundred dollars.
And, dude, he didn't even bat an eye. He's like, that sounds good.
He's like, honestly, I probably won't even know what's coming out.
That's awesome. Just got or somebody you got before.
No, this is the client that I got Saturday.
I love that. Guys, if you could ever get your business owners talking like that and they like to flex a little bit,
let them flex, stroke the ego a little bit.
And also, even though they're making a bunch of money, yeah, you might be able to charge them a little bit more.
But also, I'm a big believer of leaving some meat on the bone.
Charge a fair price because you could go back to that client and get the second, third, fourth, fifth deal.
So really good things that I want to point out there.
OK, Gina says we are getting deals. I love Gina's got a little pride.
She's like, Nick, you're talking smack. I'm over here getting deals.
She says we have deals in the works right now. We're on track for our quarter one goals.
This is perfect timing because we do need to replace a business owner.
We'll post some wins. I love it. Post some wins.
I would love to hear about it, Gina. Sean Sean says Gina is super scrappy.
I love that. Porter, get close to the mic.
Well, that was a little late, but Porter, get close to the mic.
I don't think you have. Porter, you need to get yourself a mic, dude.
No, I know. You have those lights still that I gave you?
Yeah, I got them. Are you using them right now?
No, I haven't got them on.
Get yourself a blue yeti. A hundred bucks, dude.
Listen to this. This is awesome. Nick Kudlik.
His warm network is what got me to $9,300 a month.
Nick Kudlik is somebody you guys don't know because he doesn't post.
Frickin' post, Nick, I want people to know about you.
This dude's been just working his warm network and behind-the-scenes silent killer is at $9,300 a month.
And I think he even lost the deal. I think he got over $10K just using his warm network.
You have deals in your back pocket, guys. Go fricking hit them up.
You guys know all the people with like the Mary Kay and the doTERRA and the Sensei and all these things.
Dude, you got some of these housewives that are hustling harder than you guys.
Frickin' running these shows, dude. Selling Tupperware, making more money than some of you guys.
And you guys are actually selling something that can make them money, okay?
Go get scrappy. I'm not saying to send a fricking Facebook post that says, hey, you'd be a great...
No. Follow the process the best that you can, but you got people in your warm network.
Okay, my mood. Agree, Porter. You got to hook a better B.O. immediately.
Otherwise, your heartbreak will live in your head rent-free.
A hundred percent. You got to take action quick. You got to use that...
Guys, whenever I was on the doors and I would get a no, I would never take a break, dude.
It was like next door. And I would take out all my anger on that door.
And even if I didn't do anything, it was like I felt good because I was like, no, I own that door.
They weren't interested. They weren't telling me, no, I fricking just boss that door, okay?
Sean Sean said, Gina and I lost a $1,400 offense client yesterday, but we're not crying.
The site brought 30 leads in January and over 30 leads this month.
That deal is going to be awesome.
I'm back on the phone today and excited that I will help another offense contractor make some serious money.
Exactly. And that's the beautiful thing, guys, is you have assets that are paying you 30 leads a month, dude.
That that's you could I think you guys could charge up with fencing 30 leads.
That's a $2,000 a month deal. You guys can count it as a win.
Get him under a six month contract. Good to go.
Okay, Laura Shepard, Adair said, What's the book?
Slide Edge. Read it. Do 10 pages a day. It's taking me about a month.
I'll probably finish it this week. And it's phenomenal.
Okay, Adair says I just lost a $3,000 a month deal from SEO.
They hired in-house and let me go. Had that happen, my $4,000 a month.
Same thing. They're like, yeah, I can pay somebody to bring them in-house.
Okay, Porter, what's your what's your current status?
You got another client on the hook?
I got another one on the hook. I've sent him one lead so far.
I kind of put him on the back burner just because I really want to replace these two clients.
So he's still in the works. Message him.
I told him, hey, it's not personal. I'm just busy this last week.
So this week, as soon as I get some leads, going to pass them over, going to close them.
Also, I will say I was nervous to get these people on the phone because one of these clients,
the guy that was making $2,000 a year, I didn't feel like I'd send them enough leads.
Like, you know, you ever get to that point where you're like, I don't know,
because if you don't send them enough leads or you don't gain enough trust, they just won't.
There'll be objection after objection. So I was nervous.
But that Friday, I was like, and you had talked about, you're like, dude, you got to have deals on the weekend.
I was like, dude, I'm just going to send it because if they're going to say no,
I need to find somebody today and get something else rolling.
So anyways, I'm really glad that I pushed that client.
The other one, I'd send him really good leads. I was really confident in.
But this one, I was like, I don't know, it could go either way.
But I'm sure glad I did because I did send him enough leads and I felt like I communicated enough that he wanted that.
So don't be afraid. Take imperfect action because, dude, it doesn't need to be perfect.
Everybody's different.
I love that. I've sent people one.
There's people I've closed. I sent one lead.
I sent one lead. They didn't even, not only did they not close it, they didn't even quote it.
But that was enough. Guys, sometimes when you do this long enough, you start to feel it in your gut.
You start hearing things they're saying. They're really friendly with you.
They're talking about working together in the future.
You kind of start to get these like little cues.
You just got to go for it, even though you don't feel 100 percent confident.
Sometimes one lead is all they needed because they might have done it without a lead.
That was just the cherry on top.
So, guys, in closing, because it's eight o'clock, it's eight o'clock MST and we've got to go make some money.
I got 20 minutes with the kids and I'm back here for the next eight hours at this desk.
Guys, if you have clients that are not paying you, don't accept it.
Go find a new client. If you have clients that aren't paying you enough, don't accept it.
If you've got clients that are freaking playing around with you, dancing around with you,
remember that you guys are the ones that have the quote, you know, the golden rule quote.
They say, do unto others.
And then the real golden quote is like the person that has the gold makes the rules, right?
You're the one that has the gold. You're the one that has the leads.
They have cash. Yeah, but everybody has cash, right?
Like everybody has cash. You can go work with somebody else.
So, guys, don't accept it.
Raise your standards of what you're willing to tolerate and raise your standards of how much money you need to make.
So, guys, let's go make some money.
That's it. See you next week.
Yep. Bye.